what role does U.S play
in this war could they have done
something to avoid the war
uh the devil to play in forcing Vladimir
Putin's hand
do they have a role to play in um
de-escalating the war towards a peace
agreement and the opposite if it does
escalate
towards something like the use of a
tactical nuclear weapon are they to
blame are we to blame oh man somebody
sent an email a while ago with great
words
um there's a specific way to navigate a
conversation where you can kind of like
contribute to a negative event but
you're not really the one responsible
for it like the classic example is a
woman goes out late at night gets a
little bit too drunk and then something
happens and it's like well there might
have been steps you could have taken to
mitigate the risk it's not her fault of
what happened because the responsibility
rests on the on the agent making the
choice right there's a Chooser at some
point that is choosing to do wrong or
evil
I don't believe in any of the arguments
that say the United States has
contributed to Russia's position on
Ukraine or the actions they've taken on
Ukraine there are several arguments that
some people uh some even political
Scholars are are putting out there to
say that the United States is to blame
but I find them completely unconvincing
I think that when you ask the question
of like what is the United States role
or what has their role been I think it's
really important for us I don't think we
even agree as a country on what our role
should be which I think is a hard one
because you've got this kind of there's
this growing populist movement in the
United States it might be the far left
and the far right and I think populous
tend to have this kind of isolationist
view of the world where the United
States should just be our own thing we
shouldn't be telling anybody what to do
we shouldn't be the World Police and
then kind of more in these like Center
left center right positions and then
across a lot of Europe you've got well
okay the United States is kind of like
the big kid on the Block like we're
looking to them for guidance and
Leadership on situations like what's
going on in Ukraine so and so far as uh
the original question is like what what
is like the United States responsibility
I think we have a responsibility to
ensure the relative like Freedom
prosperity and stability across Europe I
think that defending Ukraine's
sovereignty and right to their borders
is a part of that and I don't believe
that prior to the invasion in 2022 I
don't think the United States was
contributing to Russia invading that
country I know there are arguments given
that like the expansion of NATO you know
has something that's been threatening to
Russia but the baltics joined and Russia
didn't do anything about it the invasion
to Crimea was very clearly a response to
the revolution in 2014 The Invasion on
the borders is clearly a response to
Ukraine winning that Civil War in the
Southeast and the donbos and Russia
becoming more aggressive I don't think
that you can blame any of that on on
NATO expansion there's no NATO countries
that are threatening Russia or debating
Russia do you think there is a nuclear
threat
do you think about this do you worry
about this that there is a threat of a
tactical nuclear weapon being dropped I
think that possibility exists either way
and I think the responsibility for that
is on Russia because it can't it just
can't be the case that if you have nukes
you're allowed to invade countries and
take their land because of anything I
think that that down the road also
increases increases the potential for
nuclear problems in the future right
because at that point either every
single country has to acquire their own
nuclear weapons because if you don't
Russia is going to mess with you or
every single country has to join NATO
and now what we're back at square zero
Ground Zero square one where people like
oh well look all these countries joining
NATO is aggressive towards Russia like
what are you gonna do
yeah you've mentioned that um there's a
complicated calculus going on with the
countries that have uh they have nuclear
weapons and what's our responsibility
are you allowed to do anything you want
to countries that don't have nuclear
weapons
that's a really tricky discussion for
sure because what is UI supposed to do
if Russia drops a tactical nuclear
weapon there's a set of options
none of which are good
and it's such a tricky moment right now
because uh the things that Biden and
other public figures say I feel like has
a significant impact on the way this
game turns out because I think mutually
sure destruction is partially a game of
words now I mean I believe in the power
of conversation
of leaders talking to each other I feel
like
you have to have a balance between
threat and compromise
and like
empathy for the needs the geopolitical
the economic needs of a Nation but also
sort of respect
and represent your own interest so it's
a tricky one like how do you play the
how do you play the hand it reminds me
of um I don't know if you've ever heard
in like evolutionary psych Evolution or
biology there are things called Tit for
Tat strategies it kind of reminds me of
that where it's like if like uh there
are a whole bunch of these little
biological mechanisms where creatures
will develop like socializing like Tit
for Tat if you do something bad to me
I'm gonna do something bad for you and
then more complicated schemes will come
out where it'll be like tit tip for Tat
or it's like you can make one mistake
and then I'm gonna get you if you do a
second one or it could be Tit for Tat or
they're gonna be Tit for Tat tat there's
like all these like back and forths
where creatures kind of optimize
themselves and
um yeah I think something the United
States did really well in terms of that
kind of conversational strategy and I
approved of this in the beginning was
Biden was very clear about setting out
like the exact level of U.S involvement
for the war we're not going to do a
no-fly zone there's not going to be US
troops on the ground in Ukraine but we
are going to send a whole bunch of money
and a whole bunch of arms and a whole
bunch of Intel to them and I thought he
did a good job at laying out like the
limitation of the OS involvement while
opening as much as we could in the ways
we could help but the um yeah that
looming threat of some sort of tactical
nuclear weapon I think on the table
right now is like it's going to be the
annihilation of like Russian sea forces
and everything but you know what happens
if it continues to escalate that's like
a world that nobody wants to nobody
wants to be in yeah
so we talked about difficult
conversations and again thank you so
much for reviewing the yay conversation
let me ask you about Putin
speaking of difficult conversations so
if you sit down if I sit down with
somebody like Vladimir Putin or Vladimir
zielinski what's the right way to have
that conversation oh man we can talk
about that one we could talk about
somebody more well understood
through history like some like Stalin or
Hitler somebody like that maybe that's
an easier example to illustrate
how to handle extremely difficult
conversations yeah I mean I can handle
really difficult conversation between
like two people
um leaders of countries though you're
there's so much that you are
representing in that conversation I
guess the thing that would be
interesting to me
would be like what is Vladimir Putin's
interest like what is the genuine
interest that he has in the conflict
because I think finding out like what is
your buy-in or what is your like what is
the driving force keeping you here is
probably the most important thing
um I think for zelensky I think it's a
it's quite a bit more simpler because
he's he's on the defense so it's
defending his country and his people
um for Putin I've heard all sorts of
things uh you know Dugan has his
writings on uh you know like the East
versus the West the collapse of the West
and the face of like all of the
liberalism and the weird LGBT stuff that
they criticize you've got the desire to
like return to this like former Soviet
union-esque thing you've got Putin's
quotes that collapse of the Soviet Union
was the biggest geopolitical disaster
you know of 20th century and I guess
figuring out like what is Putin after
I'm not actually sure I don't know the
answer that question a lot of people
write about it but yeah well there's a
lot of answers to that question there's
a lot of answers that he can give to
that question so say I sit down with him
for three hours and talk about it
I think
this is a really interesting distinction
because you do do difficult
conversations in the space of ideas but
also in your stream you have I mean
there's a bunch of drama going on
there's there's a human psychology is
laid out uh in its full richness before
you so to me with leaders I think
a part of the conversation has to be
about the human psychology sure
not like a meta conversation but like
really understand what they feel what
they fear who they are as a human being
like as a family man as a as a person
proud of their country as a person with
an ego as a person who's been affected
if not corrupted by Powers all of us can
be and likely are so all of that that
gives context to then the answers about
what do you want in this war because the
answers about what you want in this war
will be political answers it's like it's
like a game that's being played again
with words and politicians are
incredibly good at playing that game I
think the deeper truth
comes from understanding the human being
from which those words come